Still reviewing my genetic info, one supplement histamine scavenger is needed, but I also see histoclear and natural clear hist.
Which one do I take? So histamine scavenger is the one that I would take.
So this is the one that I would take. The histamine scavenger is, and it's our private label, it's called clear histamine scavenger.
It is, I think, the better, so let's define these histamine scavenger is a product that will help pull histamines out of your body.
And natural clear hist is another product that will help pull histamines out of your body, totally different than histoclear.
So these two here, hist, clear histamines scavenger and natural clear hist are just two products that have a different components.
That's why we carry them both. That's why we've private labeled them both, because some people will do really well with the natural clear hist, and some people will do really well with the clear histamine scavenger.
And the reason why I'm recommending this one is a greater percentage of the population do well with this blend of nutrients in the clear histamine scavenger. They're different. They're some crossover, but they're very different.
The histoclear is totally different, histoclear is the DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine in the gut.
Neither one of these have the DAO enzyme, so the histoclear and the only ones that we have with the DAO enzyme, well, we have multiple, but the histoclear and the A, B, P, one assist.
This is also has the DAO enzyme. So why would you, why would you prefer a DAO enzyme product over one that will pull histamine out of the tissues?
Well, if your main inflammation is in the gut because of histamines, then you could use a DAO enzyme product.
We have some people that have mass cell syndrome where they have severe histamine issues. They really need to use both. So they need to use histoclear, the DAO enzyme or ABP one assist with each meal.
And then they take the clear histamine scavenger and some even take the natural clear hist too, as well, between meals to help pull, you absorb that and you help pull that out of the tissue. You really don't absorb the DAO enzyme. It's really working in the gut.
So there's two different, completely different products. So I would take the clear histamine scavenger by vitamin A is low. So well, actually, we don't know if you're vitamin A is low, based upon your genetics, but you have a gene that helps you utilize a and that you have defects on. And then I recommended vitamin A. So this is the product that I'd recommend.
Okay, I told you last week that I was going to tell you which one it is an email you apologize because I forgot.
It's a designs for health product, hypo, emulsia, I can't remember how much is about 30 bucks, but you only want to take a couple drops. It's a very concentrated product and you only want to start with taking like two or three drops, not drop or false drops. So this whole model is going to last you, you know, up an entire year or more.
So just two or three drops per day of this because I originally suggested the ADK and that's usually good for everybody, but I know you have issues with D and your D levels were already really high.
So this one does not have D in it. This is just the a and it's very concentrated.